selena the series part two is finally
out i'm curious have you been on social
media have you been checking out like
the fan reaction what have you seen
i try to make a habit of not going
online my motto is
do your best work give the best
performance be as honest as you can be
on screen and then
forget about it but you know i'm human
so
i i do i snoop here and there but for
the most part i try to i try to stay
away from it
okay have you snooped at all i i feel
like everyone for the most part is
really
happy which i'm pleased with because you
know this was a big deal for me i've
been a fan of selena my entire life and
this meant so much to me and i was so
nervous and i just wanted to do a good
job so
when i see people happy i mean
it's it's all you can ask for i'm
[Music]
thrilled
moments where you're at the houston
astrodome where you're at the grammys
those like really key pivotal selena
moments
you absolutely nailed what was your
research
process like where you were you know
really diving in and
embodying these these crucial moments it
was just studying the moments that we
were going to be
filming as much as i could and just
looking for those those tiny tiny
details you know like
things like the grammys i thought it was
so interesting myself
she even does her speech in a different
way that we've ever seen her speak
for me i noticed a difference in in her
speech pattern and and how she accepted
that award i'd like to thank capital emi
latin
jose bahar for making tonight possible
and having faith in us four years ago
i'm really glad i paid attention to
those things and i'm so happy that
people noticed those things it made me
like all warm
100 and i personally love that you had
the lipstick on the microphone always
yes you know i want to talk to you for a
second about youtube because it
in my opinion it's a blessing and a
curse it's wonderful that we have this
platform that gives us so much footage
of the real selena and what her life was
like in her work
but then we also have people who are
like you know let's do a side by side
and let's compare the details and the
nuances
what do you feel about that i love that
i got
to utilize it as a method of studying
but i also i understand what this is
right when you play somebody
who has lived somebody who's made an
impact the way that selena has
and just lately what we're doing with
films and television that focus on
you know a celebrity's life is people
do side by sides that is now a term used
in this industry is ah the side by side
the side by side
for me i don't like that for me i'm like
we shouldn't be worried about the side
by side we shouldn't be worried about
people comparing
my focus was her
and just being as honest as i could in
my portrayal of her
spirit i'm never gonna be selena i'm
never gonna look identical
to selena i'm never gonna move no matter
how many people
help me and train me i'm never gonna
move identically to her nobody will
nobody ever will
and because of that i went
screw the side by side we just need to
focus on
bringing her energy and her soul back
and that spirit
but that is what happens it comes with
the territory so
i was like well since we're here and
since we're in it and since it's
something that we're talking about i
have to try that's all i can do and
it'll never be perfect
but i'm happy with what we did the white
grammy dress and the
the updo hairstyle it's just timeless
and iconic so the first time that you
got to see yourself in the dress with
your hair and makeup on
what was your reaction if i focus too
much about what i'm doing
or how kind of excited i am to live in
this moment
i don't think i'd be able to work i
never really get
excited or jarred or like oh my god this
is it i'm her i feel like her i can't
believe i'm in this moment
as i just work and so actually a couple
times hiro our
director and ep had to come over to me
she knew me so well
and say remember to enjoy this remember
to realize where you are right now
and every time she said that to me i
would just cry
because i was so i couldn't believe
where i was i couldn't believe i was
getting to tell this woman's story
and um and and so that that's what would
happen to me when i thought about it
um so i just i would just focus on the
work i want to talk a little bit about
chris and selena's love story do you
selena quintanilla
take christopher gilbert perez as your
lawfully wedded husband
i do i now pronounce you
man and wife you may kiss the bride
have you had a chance to chat with the
real chris or connect with him hear what
he thinks about the series
no and i would love to you know i got to
uh
i got to chat with susette and i you
know being such a fan of selena you
imagine like oh it'd be so nice to have
met her to have spoken to her family to
hear anecdotes about her
anything and um and so i'd like to speak
with all of them you know they all have
different relationships with
with her um and i would love to you know
hear whatever he had to say about her
people ask me
what was what did you and suzette talk
about and i you know
it's that's private i'm gonna keep that
private if chris is watching this
interview is there anything that you
would like to
say um just hi
and thanks and i hope you liked it and
you know i'd love to chat
i would be remiss to not ask you about
the final episode and i have to tell you
as such a fan
it was tough for me to get through that
episode so i cannot imagine
for you as an actress what it must have
been like to be there in those moments
in those final scenes
i don't think anyone really focused on
that last episode or those last scenes
it the the filming process was so much
about her life
and how joyful she was and how wonderful
she was
that we forgot that you know at the end
we were gonna have to film
this very sad moment so i kind of
blacked out but
on the day it really hit me and it
didn't hit me until i was sitting in the
car
and i realized that i was i was wearing
the same clothes i was
i was wearing the same everything and i
was like oh man i'm playing my
like my idol and i'm i'm kind of walking
in the same
steps she did before this terrible
moment and that was
awful um i was like i don't want to do
this again i don't want to do this ever
again this is terrible this sucks
um and it is what it is i i think that
we did it in a very beautiful way you
know it wasn't about
the terrible moment it was about how
tragedy can affect the people around you
i think
and i think that's more compelling and i
love that you end
with something happy like bitty booty
boom boom a song that makes us
all smile
[Music]
is there one scene or one performance
that you're just
truly so excited to to give to the fans
i don't watch things that i do
so i i i didn't watch the first season
in its completion and
i i didn't want to watch the second part
but i watched
the astrodome and i just think it's
something really special that i haven't
seen done before and i just think
everyone did a really good job hell i
think i did a good job so i'm happy to
happy for people to see it you've done
such a brilliant job
telling not only an important story
about a musical icon but she's a woman
who is part of you know the latinx
landscape and so my question to you is
what do you do next i want to tell all
sorts of stories
white actors don't have to play
their ethnicity but we always have to
play ours and i'm very proud of my
heritage
and i want to tell stories of very
strong mexican women
i want to be able to tell stories of
amazing
um you know latin men i want to
be able to tell a story that doesn't
focus on my heritage because that's
allowed i'm allowed to do that too
but i think that's the point is being
able to do
whatever i want to do and i want those
doors to be open and i'd like to
hopefully open those doors for other
people too
the idea of playing someone who is a
real life figure
would you do it again or is that
daunting and you feel like that chapter
has closed
a couple times towards the end i was
like i'm never doing this again this is
so hard
you know the stress and all the pressure
um
then i've said this before i think that
pressure keeps you working harder it
keeps you honest it keeps you like
on the ball um and i think i might have
gotten the bug
because i i kind of like it so maybe
again
is there a name that you can share or
any names that you've thought of not yet
okay okay my baby says that all the time
not yet not yet not yet
uh well speaking of your beautiful baby
your daughter wolfie i know she's very
young but
mom is doing some real important work on
screen i'm curious if if you've shown
her
any of the clips from selena the series
i think we've played her some selena's
songs
or maybe some selena maybe we have
played her at clipper too
and um not yet
i'm busy something i don't care
for you yeah she's way cooler than i am
um but i i like that you know like i
you know she'll she'll she'll see it in
her own time and you know whatever she
makes of it she makes of it
i have no doubt she will be so impressed
and i i want to end with a very
hard-hitting question
i think one of the scenes in the series
that fans are going absolutely wild for
is when selena meets a very young
beyonce
solange and tina knowles in the mall
hold your sister's hand tied up to you
yeah what are you doing
who are you looking at who's that selena
tell me what your reaction was to when
you saw that that was incorporated in
the script and what do you make of that
fun little
pop culture nugget oh i thought it was
so cool i thought it was so cute and i
thought
you know that's what this story is about
is inspiration and
inspiring young people to follow their
dreams whatever those dreams are
and i just thought that was such a cool
moment and i did the same thing everyone
else did did that really happen
did that really happen um i think it did
i did
actually meet selena in the galleria
mall
in houston but i didn't say much to
selena
because i wasn't a celebrity and i just
saw her and said hello and kept him
moving i always make jokes about if this
means
is this gonna be my connection to
meeting beyonce i mean girl
if we if we were deprived of the selena
beyonce collab that you know would have
been fire
yeah i would love for you to finally
have a moment with beyonce that would be
unbelievable
okay well yeah let's all let's all put
that out in the universe
put it out there
you